[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais justement la température était
parfaite hier soir pour le tour de nuit
qu'elle lance officiellement la saison
du vélo si on peut dire et demain si le
traditionnel tour de l'île de montréal
avec des milliers de cyclistes avec moi
suzanne lareau pdg de vélo québec madame
l'eurobond jour au jour alors satisfait
du déroulement du cours de nuit comment
ça a été ça a été extraordinaire dans
quinze mille personnes
vous savez ces notes événement le plus
jeune lyonnais plus de jeunes qui
participent des enfants des adolescents
des jeunes adultes
alors c'est le fun de voir toute cette
foule bigarrée dans la ville de montréal
à vélo et il y avait le clou de la
soirée c'est compensé à travers le stade
olympique il y avait des symptômes dans
le scad dans l'enceinte du stade quand
les gens traversaient le stade ça a été
le moment fort pour pour les
participants de très belles soirées
c'est nouveau ça de deux parties dont le
style fait ça on essaie de faire des
trucs différents chaque année d'apporter
une petite touche on a déjà passé dans
la carrière lafarge dans l'est de
montréal que les gens connaissent pas
alors donc là on voulait donner une
touche différente le stade ça a été ça a
été ça a été un succès et demain un tour
de l'île on l'attend quoi 25 mètres
cycle 1 5 mai cycliste exactement demain
donc des parcours qui au seuil de 25 à
100 kilomètres donc 25 ou 50 km sur le
parcours à rues fermées et jusqu'à 100
km pour des gens qui veulent faire
rallonger le parcours mais sur des loups
verte à la voie partagée avec les
voitures les gens qui nous écoutent ce
matin qu'ils disent tiens j'aimerais
bien faire un tour - eh oui et non il
pas trop tard les gens peuvent
s'inscrire aujourd'hui à la maison des
cyclistes qui ils peuvent aussi se
présenter demain matin au parc jeanne
mance et s'inscrire sur place ans
présente avec son vélo puis d'un club
house & prom aspect tout à fait on
s'inscrit à des comptoirs d'inscription
et puis on peut participer tout à fait
bon et là actuellement l'on voit
justement les
et différents tracés que les gens vont
pouvoir emprunter sur deux roues demain
et non pas sur quatre routes au 6 rue là
seront fermées pendant plusieurs heures
demain à bien sûr il ya eu beaucoup de
nouvelles vélo cette semaine le fameux
rêve le réseau express vélo qui a été
annoncé par la mairesse valérie planque
avec 184 km de réseau cyclable qu'il y
aura vous avez parlé des délais vous
êtes un peu déçu de voir que ça va
prendre autant de temps à réaliser tout
ça en fait on le sait pas combien de
temps ça va prendre c'est un beau projet
c'est vous faut pas parler d'autres au
jam pas tellement l'expression autoroute
c'est plutôt des voies plus directe pour
les cyclistes pour pouvoir se rendre
dans des pots de destinations comme le
centre-ville et donc on nous parle de 31
km d'ici la fin 2021 donc son respect
que cet échéancier là c'est très bien
mais on ne va pas parler de l'échéance
est du reste du réseau et donc comme on
veut faire 184 km à terme j'aimerais
qu'on nous parle de l'échéancier et
j'aimerais bien qu'on prenne pas 25 ans
pour réaliser 184 km de voie protégée
pour les cyclistes qui vont vraiment
permettre d'augmenter les déplacements à
vélo à montréal c'est ça aussi
l'objectif de durée c'est de donner le
goût à des gens qui n'utilisent pas leur
vélo parce que ils sont craintifs
la plupart le frais le principal frein
usage du vélo en ville c'est que les
gens on part on parle de quoi on parle
de la cohabitation avec les voitures on
parle de la circulation est donc ce
réseau là devrait convaincre beaucoup de
gens qui font déjà du vélo de
l'emprunter au quotidien c'est ça le
pari du rêve
il ya eu beaucoup de réactions quand
même mitigé cette semaine par rapport à
cette annonce là l'industrie du
camionnage qui s'inquiète concernant la
circulation en ville les commerçants
notamment sur saint denis qui savent pas
trop ce que ça va donner dans leurs
affaires et dans leur chiffre d'affaires
en fait tu devrais je dire est ce qu'un
dialogue a entamé pour que ce soit une
réussite ce projet là comment voler
vraiment la cohabitation avec les six
fils actuellement à montréal
ben tout d'abord la ville de montréal
s'est alliée beaucoup de partenaires
dans ce projet là dont l'association du
camionnage du québec car là ça
m'étonnerait peu le propos parce qu'ils
étaient tout à fait partisan du rêve
je pense que les gens qui conduisent les
camions sont tout à fait conscients
qu'ils doivent partager l'espace avec
des cyclistes et celles et ceux qui sont
sur des voies bien
protéger les camionneurs et trouvent
avantage pour les commerçants de la rue
saint denis
la rue va tellement mal la rue saint
denis on a refait des travaux énormes
on ne refait la rue à l'identique et
force est de constater que ça pas du
tout donné un regain à la la la rue
saint denis
donc moi si j'étais commerçant sur
l'action de nuit je me dirais on veut
dire et en fait on a un projet qui va
donner une signature à la rue les
commerçants de la rue rachel sont bien
au fait de la piste cyclable sur le rue
et apprécié que cette piste leur passent
devant chez eux
vous savez le rêve sur saint denis le
service va être rapidement quand ça va
être construit le 6 à 7000 personnes qui
vont passer chaque jour sur cette rue là
donc des consommateurs qui vont arrêter
facilement dans vos commerces pourquoi
parce qu'on peut a besoin de chercher un
espace de stationnement pour arrêter
acheter quelque chose c'est qu'ils
avaient favorisé
oui il existe de nombreuses études
américaines et européennes qui disent qu
effectivement ce qui était pourtant
c'est le nombre de personnes qui passent
devant votre commerce pour le nombre de
véhicules qu'elle est l'ogre à engager
un dialogue engagé et je pense qu'il
faut montrer aux commerçants que les
études qui ont été faites très sérieuse
en europe et aux etats-unis montrent que
les rues il ya des voies cyclables où il
ya plus de piétons
mais le commerce va mieux que sur des
rues où il ya beaucoup de voitures qui
passent et où il est plus difficile de
s'arrêter dans les commerces donc moi je
pense que c'est une très bonne chose
blainville on va suivre ça en tout cas
et surtout le tour de l'île oui demain
mais rendait pas à 9h15 9h15 mais le
départ s'étant de 9h15 à 10h30 environ
donc les gens qui viennent peuvent
arriver dans cette plage horaire là on
part pas tous à la même heure donc 9h15
à partir du parc jeanne mance et circuit
fermé de 25 ou de 50 km il ya personne
qui faisait qu'il que ces gars de passer
pour lui alors ce que j'aime les gens
qui peuvent le faire 1,50 express stable
dans les premiers peuvent faire sur les
cyclosportives peu face au très
rapidement s'ils veulent que les plus
jeunes en famille peuvent faire un 25 km
plus mollo il y en a pour tous les goûts
pour tous les styles de suzanne lareau
merci beaucoup et bon événement demain
merci merci merci